daniels und wenn du mein dorf
angegriffen
vielleicht war ich spiele muss man
einfach leben meine damen und herren
tennis heute glaube ich wirklich eine
aller deutlichkeit sagen in deutschland
ist das leben nicht mehr allzu
lebenswerten nicht nur dass wir einfach
über 30 grad haben
der gab ich bin gestern und müsste das
zurück nach köln gekommen es war ein 31
grad okay nicht nur dass wir schon bei
petrus verpackt haben und er besitzt
über seine eindrücke mit dem härtesten
sommer dienst überhaupt gibt nein es
gibt auch neue kein master werbung zu
allem überfluss ist also ich muss sagen
ich bin immer wieder überrascht bisher
habe ich ihn schon zwei videos über call
master gemacht hat über schlechte kommen
aus der werbung in dem ersten video baby
drin weil die krankenkasse drin was ist
mit seinem freund sondern hat auch gut
dass es das line-up passiert an den
start gebracht hat kein master
interessant lustig werbung schlecht aber
okay gut ok einmal wir darüber macht
lassen wir es dabei ist es nicht
geblieben sie haben noch werbung mit
daniela katzenberger gemacht und jetzt
ganz neue brandneue leute ich freue mich
riesig verkünden zu dürfen dass wir auch
pietro lombardi an die köln master app
verloren haben
er macht jetzt auch werbung dafür gut
ich meine ich hab jetzt persönlich auch
nichts gegen pietro lombardi im
gegenteil ich bin ja fast geneigt
bisschen vorsichtiger zu sein weil er
auch viel mit revidierten sie mir mal in
den stores und hier auch ein bisschen
kontakt dass wir mehr wissen vorsichtig
aber leute ich glaube man kann rein
gewissens sagen dass pietro lombardi
durchaus dafür bekannt ist auch mal
etwas speziellere werbung zu machen wir
erinnern uns an diesmal wohl für ein
mcdonalds burger einen song gemacht hat
wollte ich wieder fixe mitarbeiter was
hier mit dem video sehen es gibt einige
neuerungen die wir uns anschauen werden
und über die wir zusammen lachen werden
falls ihr noch auf diesem kanal und oder
falls dieses video fertig dann lassen
wir gerne aber damit mich freuen und
jetzt firma die werbung wir jetzt sehen
weil die leute schon wissen eltern
falls ihr euch fragt sie was zum
versicherungsexperte call meistern haben
wir wollen nur den frischen shit ihr
werde gleich sehen brauchen wir dazu
brauchen wir schauen jetzt mal kurz das
hier an machen uns darüber lustig aber
nicht gesehen und gleich wird das eine
besondere bedeutung haben
[Musik]
na ja es ist wieder komplett ohne
jegliche mühe ohne jegliche überprüfung
vom skript einfach so abgedreht worden
mittlerweile glaube ich wirklich leute
es gibt so einfach so eine allgemeine
regel so in der marketingabteilung bei
köln master falls es die überhaupt gibt
und diese allgemeine regel besagt unsere
werbung müssen müssen
seltsam sein okay wir wollen in unseren
werbung auf gar keinen fall irgendein
eine schlüssige steuern und ich denke ja
das macht sogar häufig sind nur das
könnte im echten leben so passieren auf
gar keinen fall wäre ja hier auch eine
fremde frau die einfach eine tür kommt
und irgend so ein kind macht ihr auch
und sie begrüßt das kind mit hey baby
sonst dazu sagen so entschuldigung ist
seine mutter zu hause keine frage hey
baby und das kind so
[Musik]
naja natürlich wieder eine herzhafte
lacher leute lustig und was für ein
zufall das kind und mutter gleichzeitig
sprechen und die mutter sagt nein habe
ich nicht ob das kind sagt ja und es
verrät die mutter damit dass ein scheiß
wird es wenn wir auch vielleicht kurz
war darüber sprechen auf welchen drogen
dieses kind ist dieses gesicht alte
glaube dort mehr fragen auf welchen
drogen dieses kind nicht ist sollten wir
champions darf angreifen leute kein
basta bitte könnt ihr nicht einmal eine
werbung machen die irgendwie so halbwegs
sinn macht da muss man nach jeder werden
hier setzen und sie wusste zusammenhang
don't often ja okay gut verstanden dass
es die tante daran war mein argument hat
eben ein bisschen hinfällig okay gut
alles klar soweit okay ist das war
vielleicht auf dem weg das seltsam aber
keine komplett dann chappell daneben
eine neue wasserleitung zu sein
bis zu diesem letzten authentischen satz
[Musik]
warum warum muss immer dieses spiel
lieben bewusste zusammen also das ist
schon sehr sehr gute leute aber jetzt
gebt euch die neuen master clips mit
daniela katzenberger und pietro lombardi
und verhaltet den hätte mir gesehen
damit im hintergrund hallo kleiner
kannst du mein dorf angegriffen
hmm leute erkennen wir da irgendwelche
parallelen irgendwelche ähnlichkeiten
nein oder da die geniale köln macht der
marketingabteilung wieder mal
zugeschlagen
wir hatten vorher schon einen clip auf
deutsch übersetzt dafür auch geld
bezahlt und übersetzung und machen dann
den gleichen clip eins zu eins noch mal
und nehmen daniela katzenberger dafür
der die wahrscheinlich auch noch keine
ahnung 40.000 euro dafür bezahlen
mussten oder 100000 das ist richtiger
weiß auch was heutzutage in der welt du
mein dorf angerechnet ja warum es ist
dann immer das gleiche man denkt keiner
an milchkühe master denkt keiner an denk
dir nicht aber die leute die mir die
werbung anzeigte wir haben auch kein
bock immer das gleiche zu sehen ob wir
ein bisschen abwechslung wenn wir die
werbung schon mal eins zu eins mit
anderen darstellen gesehen haben dann
mach dir halt nicht noch mal genauso
gradwohl diese frau dann okay vielleicht
war es die muss man einfach leben ja
noch mehr als klatschen und die eigene
anerkennung zeigen kann man wirklich
machen in diesem fall bei dieser
wirklich authentischen aussage von
daniela katzenberger sehr kann mir quasi
so aus ihrer außen also wer jetzt
behauptet dass die irgend jemand der die
textzeile vorgeschrieben hat und die
gezwungen hat es zusagen für geld ich
kann man sowas denken muss man einfach
lieben
auch hier doch mal warum muss man dieses
spiel lieben
warum wo ist der grund warum muss ich
dieses spiel lieben
ich habe keine liebe übrig für dieses
spiel mich diese nerven werden fangen ja
genau wie westdeutschland ganz
deutschland ist an dieser werbung
genervt reger seitdem ich dieses video
serie macht was ich sehen ob diese zwei
videos marco maser je tag alle fünf
minuten
heute auf install direct friedlichen
master werbung und fange sich darüber ab
dass sie wie sehen
ich will dieses spiel nicht lieben
müssen daniela was ich mit dir hast du
willst so viel gold master geld bekommen
da hab ich noch ein letztes mal mir das
anschauen wird heute bitte einfach noch
mal um so zu sehen sowieso authentische
werbung im jahr 2019 aussehen muss dies
bewusst man einfach leben
[Musik]
aber das war noch nicht alles leute ich
habe noch einen länger für euch und zwar
ein pietro lombardi der hat nach seinem
song über den pizza magna über einen
burger von mcdonald's bis jetzt einfach
so einen seiner inneren musikalischen
überzeugung gefolgt und hat sich als ok
ich meine entwicklungsgeschichte als
künstler okay ich stelle mir so vor
wohin will ich als künstler hin was ist
der nächste stopp
ich mache einen song über die coil
master app ja okay leute ist ein
bisschen langsamer machen und geben als
die erste fünf sekunden gesehen und
diese werbung damit an dass pietro
lombardi singt ich greife dich an du
greifst mich an
ja okay also das sind kriegerische
handlungen der da beschreibt aber so
über sie überzeugt ich kräftig ja du
kriegst mich an häufig stern zerstörung
und tod oder wird sich dadurch pietro
lombardi könnte so über alles so einen
song machen und es wird irgendwie so
halbwegs hebb ick bin egal selbst bei
einem song über blasen am fuß
ok wenn die schule zu eng sind
[Musik]
ok jetzt hier wissen inception leute
also diese ganze szene ist so zu deuten
sie sind quasi bei dem musik video dreh
für pietro lombardis 9 song über die koi
master ab und da vollkommen ohne grund
tanzt eine halbnackte frau mit
warum was was bringt das leute das ist
ein guter guter messfaktor um so zu
erfassen wie lost man so im leben ist
wie lost seid ihr heute leute auf einer
skala von null bis halb nackt zum kein
master song von pietro lombardi tanzen
[Musik]
was auch hier werden sehr authentische
reaktion von pietro lombardi
was mein gott
ein dorf angegriffen
[Musik]
ich bin ja dann hat schon war irgendwie
der der typ der den ventilator an dem
set bedient oder was ist hier bediente
sitzt einfach hinter dem ventilator das
ist einmal seine aufgabe über diese
musik video dreht man sich langweilig
was wird hans hans greift das dorf von
pietro lombardi an pedro ist natürlich
geschockt weil wer sollte damit rechnen
was und dann am ende hören wir die
wundervolle leyen ich bin so wundervoll
ich bin der coin master muss dazu noch
irgendwas sagen ich bin wundervoll ich
bin der kein master vermeiden meine
meinung dazu ist nein leute schreiben
der schule würde man die kommentare was
ihr aktuell macht bei der hitze um
irgendwie durch den tag zu kommen
irgendwie zu überleben habt ihr
irgendwelche tipps was man machen kann
um nicht direkt zu sterben ich muss an
der stelle das video leider werden leute
zu themen beim tattoo studio habe jetzt
hier über die stirn
die zeile ich bin wundervoll ich bin der
coil master tätowieren lassen in diesem
sinne leute drüben für euch
vorgeschlagen das video ab das wasser
weit von mir ich größere augen bis zum
nächsten mal